foreign
folks and welcome to rational science
the only site on the internet that does
physics rationally everybody else does
mathematics they do a bunch of equations
and give you the most irrational
explanation they can find mechanisms
yeah none of them work none of them can
be even imagined they tell you they
cannot Be Imagined and everybody says
yeah okay
we'll never figure it out
and nobody catches that nobody picks up
on that everybody just believes what
Authority passes down to them anyways we
got a great day today we're going to be
talking a little bit about leaving the
planet
uh people want to escape reality so they
want to look for ways out you know one
way is uh to go to Mars you know even to
the Moon close by here another one is uh
maybe travel on a gravity wave subject
of today
okay so let's go with our extension
segment let's see if we can escape the
planet okay let's find out about that
here's uh some news that came out this
week okay and uh it's got to do with uh
our expedition to Mars okay it goes like
this one year on Mars NASA analog
astronauts begin mock red planet Mission
today and you can watch it live uh what
is all this about well they're preparing
some people uh apparently three
astronauts I think four are gonna go I
don't know why they're preparing three
but they're going to be sending three uh
four astronauts to Mars two of them will
descend on the planet and do their thing
and then they're gonna come back and
that's gonna happen according to this uh
note uh anywhere between the late 2030s
and the early 2040s
and the question is whether this is ever
going to happen okay
um
says the down round trip travel will be
500 Days okay that's over a year you
know 365 days a year it's going to take
about a year and a half more or less and
that's just go coming that's just going
and coming back okay and uh you can see
some of the uh things that you got to
tell you 25 tons of Supplies and
Hardware would be ready and waiting for
the crew delivered by a previous robotic
Mission and then they go over some of
the problems that they're going to
encounter like gravity which will be the
biggest problem right
okay so we're going to Mars apparently
will we will we ever get to Mars
and more fundamentally uh why why do we
want to go to Mars I mean uh here we
have uh four people apparently they want
to go to Mars or they will be sent to
Mars are we ever going to evacuate the
Earth eight billion people and move to
Mars is is that a possibility uh
terraform as Carl Sagan would say you
know terraform the planet yeah is that
ever going to happen
um or are we just going to evacuate the
jails the prisons and send all these
people out there and say well we're
going to send you out there
to Mars okay who's going to go to Mars
who's going to live in Mars are we going
to start a colony like you know when
Columbus uh came to America you know uh
shortly afterwards you know all the
Europeans were coming to America uh
stealing Land from the Indians you know
and doing their thing is that what's
going to happen to Mars uh for sure I
don't think we're going to encounter any
martians that are waiting for us you
know that we don't have to worry about
displacing them or giving them bugs or
whatever but will we ever colonize Mars
and that's something for you to think
about you know
um
and uh these people are going to be
doing something similar to what uh was
done in the 1990s I think 93 94 and
that's this biosphere too you know I
went to Biosphere 2 down south near
Tucson in Arizona and they had eight
people enclosed in there
um purely very much like the eight mice
with which Calhoun started his
experiment his Mouse experiment anyways
they lived there and apparently they
divided up in groups and they had
problems with each other and they did
two experiments and then they shut it
down and since then they've been selling
this uh complex from one organization to
another they haven't done anything else
in there I think it's just a tourist
attraction now that's that's about it
but they still have the place there for
people to live if they ever want to do
the experiment again and
and the question is this other one the
one for Mars are they going to be doing
the same thing they're going to be
putting these three people inside a
place for over a year and see see if
they what kind of problems they run into
you know both uh physical as well as
mental right
um because remember these people are
going to be traveling for over a year
year and a half round trip uh and so
they wanna
try to figure out what kind of problems
they might run into
and my question is is all of this worth
it I mean we might as well send robots
right to to Mars maybe more
sophisticated robots maybe R2D2 kind of
robots that you know walk and do the
things and lift things and so on uh I
think that's a better deal than sending
humans down there I mean what's the
point of that
especially you know they go lower them
onto the planet come back up and come
back home
uh like we did
particularly by the moon
um
I don't know I think it's kind of like a
waste of
um
resources
and the question is whether you you know
as a taxpayer would want to support such
a venture right so these are things that
people should consider now uh in in
these uh projects usually they develop a
lot of technology and that part's good
no Pro no problem there but sending
people out there I don't know just the
insurance on the lives of those people
must cost a lot even though they're
taking risks anyways they also have this
project Artemis going to the moon and I
checked it says NASA's human lunar
exploration plans under Artemis call for
sending the first woman and first person
of color to the surface of the Moon
and yeah I did check and they're legal
they have a diversity inclusion
Department okay they they covered that
base and so what I'm suggesting is that
you know maybe they should send a trans
person out there you know that way they
cover all the bases men women hopefully
uh this person is both Jewish and has a
black father and a Chinese mother you
know and brother who is Buddhist and
that way we cover all the bases and we
don't have to worry about offending
anyone you know how's about that okay
that's my five cents worth on that
uh again I don't know why we're going to
the Moon uh especially with people
um maybe we can send some robots that
can do some Excavating some machines and
the robots handle the whole thing and we
can bring whatever
minerals we need here on Earth that I
can understand but sending people
uh what's the point of that are we ever
going to live on the moon certainly we
can't terraform the moon because too
little we can't get gravity or air in
there in the quantities that we would
need uh so we would always have to be
you know
um suited up and living in some kind of
uh you know house that we built out
there for him some place
and uh so here's my five cents worth on
the moon landings uh for people who say
well Bill we never went to the moon okay
and so you know I kind of
summarize here what the typical
arguments against the moon landings are
uh many people say that a lot of that
was done in Hollywood or could have been
done in Hollywood and my counter
argument against that is you know it's
an invalid argument unless you can tell
us the difference if you cannot tell us
the difference between doing it in
Hollywood and the real thing
then you don't have a case you can't
bring that argument up only if you can
tell the difference okay if everything
they did on the moon could have been
done in Hollywood you don't have a case
um and they say well we have uh there we
saw this air and the other air and the
other air uh well I didn't tell you if
this was done in Hollywood directors
wouldn't have made so many errors
basically catastrophic errors so the
more errors you find the more uh you're
the the weaker your argument is okay so
keep that in mind don't find more errors
because if you found one little error
that's one thing but when you find 100
errors and something's wrong with your
interpretation okay about the physics up
there and some people think it's
physically impossible to go to the Moon
you know uh we can't go through uh the
magnetism that surrounds the Earth or
the
um
solar wind that hits us once we're out
in space and so on they have all these
Notions I think a lot of that's just a
misunderstanding of physics
and all I can say there we built the ISS
the International Space Station we built
it in space it flies around the earth
several times a day we have satellites
out there for those of you who believe
in satellites
and they have taken pictures of the
Earth from outside the Earth how do we
get those satellites out there you know
and uh we have sent crafts to other
planets and uh
uh celestial objects
um and so the question is you know if we
can send a craft all the way to the Moon
to go around it and come back why
couldn't we send a human inside such a
craft that's my issue there
and then uh the last one uh people say
well there's hasn't been a mission since
uh we landed on the moon that was you
know what 50 years ago and the
questionnaire is we never and the issue
that I bring there is that we had no
need for one okay there was no need uh
it was a space race essentially
and uh between Soviet Union United
States and the United States said hey we
we got the gold medal we we got there
first no problem but then what was there
to do after that uh build a colony on
the moon what would have been the
purpose of that aside from the expense
tremendous expense you know what other
profits what's coming back and the issue
is nothing
uh it could be some people might suspect
and say well you know that was 50 years
ago yeah and where are we going now well
maybe we're trying to get some uh
minerals or the explore the possibility
of extracting minerals from the Moon I
think that's the main one other than
that I don't see any purpose of going to
the moon at all certainly not to inhabit
the Moon
and same with Mars I mean I don't think
we're going to inhabit Mars ever
um maybe get there yes back there you
know get there and come back that that I
can grant it could happen uh stay there
no no way they're they're not gonna be
building anything out there and living
there uh
hundreds and thousands of people no no
way that's never going to happen so the
question is why are we doing all these
projects are we doing them to explore
to learn something about the solar
system or whatever if it's that
important you know I mean there's a
bunch of rocks around the solar system
so
now we know everything we need to know
what else do we need to know about the
solar system that is so important that
we would spend money on sending people
out there so that's exploration are we
going to do colonization
you know are we going to really send
people out there you know and and my
answer to that is flat no there's not
and that's never going to happen you
know we might send someone up there that
lands on the planet comes back that
might happen but uh live there you know
and start sending supplies and build a
colony and expand now people are
confusing Columbus with uh with the
logistics of what it would take to send
someone to Mars you know to the Moon we
can even imagine that it's close by but
to Mars a little more difficult okay
okay
um anyways here we have uh questions
that people uh
comments that people made since last
time regarding autism and homosexuality
and these two people say the following
says one says the truth will come out
soon autism is a vaccine side effect
and I think homosexuality is included as
well okay remember where you heard it
first okay thank you very much
aren't you aware of the failure of the
c19 bio weapon injection oh my God I
wasn't aware of that they were putting
injections that are what bio weapons
okay uh an NFL says I think you should
take uh School indoctrination into
account regarding orientation these days
all I can say to these people is they
should listen first before they talk I
mean I've said it several times I'm
going to say one more time I don't want
to bore everybody who's been paying
attention Okay and here it is okay
here's Calhoun's experiment this was
done with mice was done first with rats
then with mice okay and the issues the
following uh hit after a while his uh
mice uh towards the end of the project
which lasted almost two years they
became homosexual and out to several
many other mice became homosexual and
autism and a lot of them even lost all
interest in sex completely okay and so
here we have animals they were not
injected with what c19 and they did not
receive any indoctrination as far as I
know okay so that's one issue the other
one is
um
here's this one let me remove
the second here
and this is the other one
uh that I showed a couple times now here
we have Lions mounting lions and sheep
also uh doing it with sheep meant a male
sheep with male sheep and so the
question is you know this is in the wild
the in the case of the Lions it's in the
wild okay the other the Sheep obviously
are under control of humans but they're
really out there in in the pasture Etc
so they're in semi-wild I guess you
could say but the point is that you know
you have homosexuality among uh animals
and in the case of Calhoun's mice you
also had autism uh
created or generated in the lab
and no vaccines in
involved no indoctrination
you have to explain that before you go
out and say oh it's it's school it's
what we learn it's uh you know it's how
this guy was taught in at home and so on
no it's like saying you know that a
dance patient
uh was made that way at home by mommy
and daddy that he was okay until Mommy
and Daddy you know brainwashed him or
whatever or school did or or his peers
no no that guy was born that way and you
gotta explain that and I'm saying that's
got to do solely with genetics okay or
at least most of it with genetics if
there's other factors that's what can be
discussed but I don't think you can rule
out genetics at all okay what is it I'm
saying that you know we lost our genetic
diversity all humans are clones today we
have pretty much the same genetic
structure despite that we have mutations
daily uh we've had throughout history
right uh bottlenecks and founders effect
and here we are we are all descendants
of a relatively few that live uh 100 200
years ago so if you go back in time we
are all more or less brothers and
sisters in great pleasure because our
great-grandfathers whether they were in
Japan in Africa and the Americas or
Europe it doesn't matter uh they all
went through the same sifting process
with diseases diseases were the ones
that they had to overcome when they
overcame those diseases either by
natural or artificial means here we are
okay we are the descendants of those
people those who made it past the
sifting process okay that's why we're
all the same
okay and one final issue here fellow
says uh gender identity disorder was
used for its diagnostic name when it was
introduced into dsm-3 in 1980 with the
publication of DSM-5 in 2013 gender
identity disorder was eliminated and
replaced with what gender dysphoria
gender dysphoria is a handicapped uh
mental disorder and all I want to add to
that is that
um you know in 1973 that's 50 years ago
uh the American Psychiatry Psychiatric
association
um declared that homosexuality was no
longer a disorder a mental disorder
which it had been until until that point
and that was a great victory for the
homosexuals because shortly after they
were able to change the laws and say
that thing you know uh sex between men
especially those two but also Between
Women was no longer a crime which was
until then was a crime in many states at
least and around the world and sure and
shortly after that you know they just
kept changing the laws but the funny
part is that they only declared in 1973
they only declared homosexuality not to
be a disorder they left all the other
letters of the alphabet
in the code and the everyone else was
still uh committing a crime okay so keep
that in mind
okay let's move on to uh our subject of
today which is the um
gravity waves what our gravity ways well
we've been talking lately about uh
dimensions and
contrasting them against coordinates and
vectors okay and number lines especially
and so the question is
um you know when when you get into the
subject of
um
uh gravity waves you have to include
dimensions in in your discussion because
these gravity waves propagate through
space time which is four-dimensional and
they are going to talk about two
dementia especially two-dimensional
waves right propagating through
four-dimensional way space time so the
word Dimension is going to enter in
there so we can't get rid of it
completely okay and then that's one
issue the other issue is Fields okay
because they had to create a medium
through which these waves propagate or
which vibrate and represent the wave
that is reaching us and so those were
the fields so we have two words there
dimensions and Fields and those are the
ones that we need to use in order to
discuss
um
gravity waves okay so uh here's uh what
we've been talking about we had these uh
dimensions and coordinates we put them
under static Concepts in our Universal
movie and number number line and Vector
they're at the bottom together with the
Dynamic Concepts okay what are we
talking about here we're saying the
universal movie you got to think of it
as uh all we have at any cross-section
of the universal movie you could say a
cross section of motion cross-section of
time all we have is location we have
distance between every atom in the
universe that's all we have in a single
frame next frame every atom is now at a
different location that's all we have so
we have different locations of every
atom in different frames but in one
frame all you have is those static
Concepts you have distance location
existence and you have the object itself
and for example atoms right so where do
we put 40 space time you know well who
can't really fit it in there can we
in fact they tell you that for these
space space time four-dimensional
space-time is unimaginable and partly
because they're not talking about
Dimensions they're really talking about
chord I'm sorry about number lines okay
so that was the discussion in the past a
couple weeks that we've had Wormhole
Wormhole what is the 1D it's time okay
so the 1D and Warren pole represents
time that's what a wormhole is what does
it connect well it connects two Zero
Dimensional black holes singularities so
at the ends of two wormholes you have
two Zero Dimensional singularities or
black holes and so what we have is
really what mathematicians have been
talking for ages which is a line
um which is uh between two points okay
so that comes all the way from degrees
where the points Zero Dimensional that's
what they are uh geometries you could
call them geometric figures known as
Zero Dimensional or that have zero
dimensions and you have the 1D line
which is the Wormhole so essentially
what they've done is extrapolated these
geometric Concepts to uh their Notions
mathematicians right their Notions of
the universe or How the Universe really
runs okay how it works
okay so um
so why did I bring this subject up well
I was going to talk about this subject
anyway but it turns out that just by
sheer coincidence this week they had uh
several pieces of news related to
gravity waves and here's one that I just
picked up okay it says astronomers
across the world announced on Thursday
that they have found the first evidence
of long theorized form of gravitational
waves that create a background hum
rumbling throughout the Universe okay so
uh turns out that you know they had
already discovered these as you see in
the bottom line there the existence was
not confirmed until 2015. yeah they had
already in 2015 detected uh two black
holes colliding supposedly that's that's
their Theory and that they were able to
detect the gravity waves from that
collision and so the question is what
have they invented now well the
difference now is that this is a
different type of gravitational Wave
It's one that um that they can hear okay
so I guess they turned it into music or
whatever
and so uh they said it was done by many
scientists across the uh planning okay
first predicted by Albert Einstein you
always have to put Einstein in there
because otherwise your paper doesn't get
published right turns out Einstein did
not believe in gravitational waves okay
so uh just keep that in mind he wrote a
paper against it and never believed in
it ever again after that more than a
century ago gravitational waves are
ripples in the fabric of the universe
that travel through everything at the
speed of light almost entirely unimpeded
why would they be unimpeded I mean uh
they don't bounce against planets or
Suns I mean there's all kinds of garbage
out there you know that in the in its
way why would that gravitational wave
reach us almost without impacting
anything
okay so this is what you gotta that's
one of the first issues we got to look
at right
but it turns out they say it has it was
caused uh they always in order for it to
be powerful enough to reach us it has to
be caused by a collision between two
black holes and that's more or less what
it looks like there you see it okay so
they this came out I think it was today
um two black holes colliding okay and
they have a million of these pictured
people love to see these things and what
you're staring at is idiocy
irrationality complete irrationality but
people don't realize that they say oh I
understand it's a little uh Whirlpool
there they Collide and they send shock
waves outwards that's how people
understand and they never question any
of this how this uh is really
surrealistic okay they have a Zero
Dimensional two-dimensional
three-dimensional Whirlpool there in the
middle of four dimensional space-time
which is really a three-dimensional
because as you can see the background is
all just space and stars and everything
that is through dimensional okay so uh
uh just keep that in mind it's also
realistic what they're telling you what
they're showing you uh and you're not
listening to their words they're saying
Zero D that's how how big a
black hole is it's zero D it's no size
no shape okay that's how big it is it's
infinite density all black holes have
the same mass
all of them have the same math because I
mean the same density why because if the
volume is zero I don't care how much
mass it has the mass is going to be
infinite the density is going to be
infinite okay so all black holes have
the same density they should all weigh
the same nothing because matter has been
crushed out of existence okay but that's
a subject for another day and um let me
get this on the other side
here it is
here's a another version of that two
black holes and you can see now the
ripples through four-dimensional space
time you see the four dimensional uh
face space-time fishnet okay and they
say a subtle Symphony of ripples in
space-time astronomers you'd use dead
stars to measure gravitational waves
produced by what ancient black holes
what are they talking about collision
between two black holes you can see the
ripples in space time so what we need to
look at is uh you know what is that
space time and uh you know they talk
about just space-time people say well
time is a concept what do you mean
you're blending time with space What
sense does that mean they said no don't
worry they're fields
that's what we're talking about we're
talking about fields and so not only you
get out of the dimensions into the world
of fields but they really both go
together you can't do without both when
you talk about gravitational waves okay
so we have to research a little bit
about Fields what are Fields where did
this word come from
um what are they talking about when they
say feels what is this the mysterious
word called field is it a physical
object is it a medium
that's the question okay because
supposedly uh the gravity waves are
going to propagate through fields or the
vibration of the fields is the gravity
wave you can look at it either way okay
so here it is okay this is the secret
history of gravitational waves yeah you
can find in that magazine American
scientists this action at a distance
Disturbed fellow philosophers who
demanded to know how gravity was
transmitted from the Earth to the Moon
yeah good question Newton's celebrated
reply was hypothesis meaning I have no
clue
such concerns gave rise to the notion of
space filling field okay space filling
field okay so they filled space with
this field the medium okay so field is a
medium that transmits the message okay
or through which the message is
transmitted you can look at it either
way so what is a field it's a continuous
and continuously varying plane of action
what in the world is a plane of action
is that a thing
I mean I don't know what kind of plane
that is but that's what they call it the
field is a plane of action through which
disturbance propagate
eliminating the conceptual not of action
at a distance well they haven't uh
eliminated any knot they just created a
new knot well all they said is that you
know there's this other concept called
plane of action and uh that's gonna
transmit or through which the
disturbance is going to propagate
by the 1840s the cree the creators of
hydrodynamics were treating fluid
properties velocity density pressure all
as Fields yeah that's the issue today no
one doubts the reality of fields okay so
yeah it's a done deal they talk about
fields and what none of these people
ever figured out is field is not a
medium it's not a thing there's no such
thing as a field field is a region okay
region full of numbers that's all a it's
a mathematical concept has nothing to do
with physics whatsoever you can't use it
as a paddle you can't say a field did
this or the field vibrated or whatever
you can't do any of that
okay here you have um
again the the breakdown here you need
the field and dimension you need space
time is the box or sphere the container
within which we live that's the official
version okay we live within this thing
called space time so I asked a famous
question what's outside of space-time
what gives shape to the container in
other words when you look at your right
over there what's the green stuff that
either encapsulates the warp space time
right or the W map there you know the uh
the universe what is outside of it if
space-time and matter are all within
these things uh what's outside of it
that's what you got to tell us you know
and of course they say space time is
unimaginable because it is 4D for
dimensional right if we can't imagine
the 4D much less can we imagine what
encapsulates the container so that's
essentially your answer okay it's an
unscientific question we can't prove it
we can't uh you know it's a
philosophical question as far as they're
concerned so they never answer that
question on the inside of this
unimaginable container we have what math
stuff and here we have Stephen Hawking
okay and he yes for those of you who
know him he was a
mathematician who died a couple years
ago and he was uh like the king of um
of black holes okay and so he knew
everything about space-time black holes
and all that stuff everybody just paid
attention to him and so what does he say
he says that space-time is made of
points known as events and here you see
him he says an event is something that
happens
okay yeah and event if something happens
but it happens with a particular point
in space in a particular time
okay so uh we have a point
which is uh zero the dimensional okay
and he's saying a point is the
representation of a happens of an event
of a phenomenon something that happened
happened at a point
and uh so one can specify well we're
four numbers or coordinates what are
coordinates he's telling you there he's
saying they're just numbers that's it
all they're talking about is math
they're not talking about physics it is
often helpful to think of the four
dimensions and four coordinates of an
event of specifying its position in a
four-dimensional space called space-time
so what is space time made of it's
called it's made out of points and since
the particles if you want to call them
uh discrete little nuggets you know
grains of sand in other words space time
they treat it as a Sandbox okay
and then he says it's impossible to
imagine this uh this thing he calls
space-time okay great okay we learned a
lot there and then he uh you find other
people who says uh who say that
um actually space-time is full of energy
okay some substance they call Energy
whatever that is I've never seen it I've
never seen an illustration of this
energy thingy but everybody uses this
word says it's energy out there okay uh
and then of course the fields so what is
inside space and what is it made out of
uh
it's made out of all of these and uh
what they're going to be doing is using
the fields okay the one not the last the
last one there that's what they're going
to be using uh for the propagation of uh
gravity waves
okay so let's see if we can make some
sense out of all this we have four
dimensions okay and we're going to use
uh the Tesseract which is alleged to be
four dimensional okay so here we have
the Tesseract typical Tesseract a little
allergy down the sides no problem there
okay and the first question we have is
uh you know what's the black stuff there
you know we need to identify uh that
white stuff now as you can see it there
okay uh what encapsulates the tester
yeah Fifth Dimension what is that you
know I need to know what material that
is what are we going to call it just the
enclosure of space-time
and uh yeah when you look up on the sky
uh I mean we can't see the fourth
dimension but we can still see within
three dimensions and here it is within
uh three dimensions we can see stars out
there galaxies maybe especially if you
got a good scope okay
okay so uh that's what we see out there
okay
but
um these people put all kinds of stuff
out there that they say is fills the
same 3D space the one we're familiar
with right and here's uh one now this
one is the one proposed by Hawking and
that is particles okay and he's saying
that space time is really made out of
all these events these uh points okay
and that's the way they visualize them
okay and uh other people see it as
energy okay so you see this energy this
smoke I guess I don't know how to
illustrate it because you know nobody's
ever really dealt with it in any way
nobody illustrates the energy we don't
know what they're talking about but
everybody imagines that some foggy
substance I guess that's moving out
there
and others see it uh see space time you
know all this ether that's in there and
they see the ether as waves okay what's
what are waves the movement of ether and
yeah they never got rid of The Ether
they just changed the wording they call
it space time they call it whatever they
you know the false vacuum whatever the
words they use but they all mean The
Ether they haven't got rid of the
particles out there but those particles
vibrate and so they talk about waves
okay and so here it is they see it as
waves just crossing uh our 3D World the
one that the 3D Universe the one we can
see okay we can't see the 4D right
okay and um and uh so but what are waves
made out of okay because uh that's we
want to get to the bottom of it these
waves are flowing uh you can think of
them as gravity waves as well as light
waves and one of the things we're trying
to do is trying to see if they can merge
light with gravity okay so that's when I
so so you can imagine that gravity waves
might also be transverse waves okay but
uh typically they think of a man's
longitudinal waves okay well what are
these waves made out of well they're
made out of fields as we just said you
know oh give me a second here
so on the other side as always okay so
uh what are they well they're vibrating
Fields that's what they say these are
okay so that's what the waves are made
of fields in fact a transverse wave is
made out of two orthogonal mutual
orthogonal uh
uh Fields okay so this is where we're at
we're uh We've we've got space time four
dimensionals we cannot imagine we cannot
see it fine so we don't do that but in
our 3D World they say we have to detect
whatever's coming to us and they say
we've detected these I guess
two-dimensional waves transverse waves
or longitudinal waves that are coming
from the Collision of two black holes
and we detected it with these sensors
that we have here on Earth okay that's
that's essentially the pitch the sales
pitch okay and that's what you're paying
all those big bucks for you know tax
money and so on giving it to these guys
okay so here's one of the gurus today
and he uh tells you right in your face
that uh everything is feels everything
is made out of fields okay here it is
and his name is Sean Carroll and he gave
a talk at the Royal Institution the
particle at the end of the universe he
says to understand what is going on on
you actually need to give up a little
bit on the notion of particles instead
think in terms of fields aha so that was
the secret
when you hold two magnets close together
you can feel their attraction or
repulsion before they even touch
an interaction between two magnetic
fields so we have interaction between
Fields Okay so we've got to figure out
what these uh you know baseball bats are
called Fields okay how they interact
likewise you know when you jump in the
air you're going to come down come back
down that's because you live in Earth's
gravitational field so this field
apparently has some uh some powerful uh
influence over you you jump and bring
you down and you can find you know the
fields are pulling two magnets together
okay so we need to get to the bottom of
what this field is because it's this
field which is going to be coming with a
gravity wave the gravity wave is going
to come through a field or it's the
vibration of the field itself so we we
no doubt about we got to get to the
nitty-gritty here and find out what a
field is what is a field and here this
fellow tells us he says um
uh he tries to get rid of Newtonian
action at a distance he says there
really is no action at a distance
instead of just thinking about random
forces between objects very very far
away imagine there is a field filling
the universe okay whatever field is it
fills the universe and what does it mean
he says what that means mathematically
not physically okay mathematically is
that at every point in space there is a
number
so what is a field well it says uh that
at every point in space there's a number
he's talking about a region where you
have values it says in fact it says the
value of the field just like the
temperature of the air in this room at
every point there is a value the
temperature at that point of the air
so what he's saying is that a field is
just a region with a bunch of values uh
that have different strength or
different in case of temperature
different temperatures or whatever so in
the case of gravity it would be
different strengths of the gravitational
so-called field
so all he's done is give us a
description he hasn't told us how a
field does this matching he just says
look if you're over here you're going to
have so much strength from the field
gravitational field if you're over here
you get more strength over here you get
more strength okay that's all he's
saying there's there's different
strengths at different locations
okay not very useful and then he gives
us his um uh punchline his uh corollary
okay he says look uh he says
gravitational force is the slope of a
field that pervades space
in other words far away you have
um the potential field is very weak and
as you approach say for example the
Earth or a planet or whatever uh
celestial object it just gets stronger
okay and that's all he's saying oh he's
talking about is strength of a field he
hasn't told us what a field is in fact
he has told us he says a bunch of
numbers a bunch of values and certainly
we cannot pull with values we cannot
pull with numbers we cannot go with
kilograms or with uh whatever you know
whatever pounds whatever you want to use
here you can't pull with pounds you got
to explain how you pull
okay you gotta explain the physical
mechanism
and he hasn't done that all he's just
done is described says that it's
stronger over here than it's over here
okay so
uh he hasn't told he just measured
gave us a value and he says that's the
way it is yeah okay that's the way it is
you haven't told us
how that happens by what mechanism okay
what's the cause
and that's what physique is about not
measuring and give us a value and saying
that it's stronger over here than over
there okay great it's it's hotter over
here than it's over here you know like
you know you put your finger in the uh
boiling water say hey it's hot it's
hotter than out here yeah okay so what
have you told me can you tell me why
it's hotter
that's what we want to know not to tell
me over here it's cold and when I put my
finger in the boiling water is hot great
uh what do you give you a noble price
for that
okay so here's the Caltech version okay
we have these black holes and they send
out all these waves okay uh just by
their motion and here we're not talking
about uh to the Collision of two black
holes we're just saying that the black
hole sitting in space space time right
just bending this uh
what is it the sandbox
somehow sends gravitational waves to us
and these are two-dimensional waves or
longitudinal waves that are reaching us
and that we can detect okay and there
you see the waves okay these are
illustrations from them not not for me I
just borrow them to show you what they
are proposing they're saying look
there's these waves you know and they
they're coming to us and how how were
they generated well they were generated
when the black hole pushed down the
sandbox you know you have a ball
baseball maybe a bowling ball you want
okay bowling ball in a sandbox pushes
down and somehow it creates a ripple
through the sand
that comes all the way to you and pulls
on you okay let's get that straight it's
going to pull on you because it's
gravity and gravity is a pull Force it's
an attractive Force it's not a repulsive
Force okay it doesn't push you away it's
supposed to bring you inwards okay
uh like uh you know Cowboy pulling on a
rope that's tied to uh donkey you pulled
the donkey forward you don't pull like
that and the donkey goes farther and
farther away it's the other way around
okay okay so here are uh two ways of
looking at this here you have a ball
sitting in the sand and it's going to
cause this um gravity well okay this is
what they're proposing okay
and um here you have uh the ball is
going to fall through that gravity wheel
okay it's going to make you can see it
falling through there and the question
does drilling through a Sandbox okay
does that cause ripples along the
sandbox along the sand that pulls all
the other balls inwards towards it
or uh
you know first does it attract them and
second do the ripples travel through you
know the sand those are two questions
you got to ask because that's what
they're saying space time is what was
space time well it's a field and what is
a field uh value at each point in space
and what did Hawking say it's just uh
events you know points so he's talking
about a Sandbox and somehow because it's
uh black hole which taunt weighs tons
infinite weight
no problem we'll concede it weighs down
the sandbox and somehow that produces
ripples
that not only go outwards but pull you
inwards
that's the mechanism so what sense does
any of that make I don't know that's for
you to figure out okay
okay here uh here we have the situation
we have the ball pushing down uh space
time how does it track another ball
I mean we can imagine here like you know
you can't imagine the pull mechanism at
that point but if you remove that hump
okay we're gonna remove the hump
now we can imagine you know simply
because of gravity at one ball rolling
towards the other but we cannot imagine
this if uh if that hump is still there
okay so so the the issue is if you put a
ball
have you have a bowling ball
in the sand and sink it in you can step
on it and push it in all the way as far
as you want okay down to Rabbit Hole
okay does it pull
on the does it send ripples through the
sand first of all all the grains of sand
moving all the way to the to the um
tennis ball that's on the other side and
does it pull it inwards and so that's
for you to figure out if that's the case
okay and here you have two black holes
uh going around each other they're gonna
Collide eventually because of their
gravitational attraction supposedly but
what they send out are these Ripples and
they're saying that it's like uh you
know
um if they were in the water like two
stones rolling around each other in the
water and they sell all these ripples
outwards okay we can concede all that
let's assume that's the case how does
that produce attraction assuming this is
the case all the ripples go outwards how
does that attract you
okay here I'll give you a another uh
version or another analogy here you have
uh sound okay someone speaks it vibrates
all the air around him okay and the
sound waves go outwards okay so you have
all these actually longitudinal waves
moving outwards from the speed the
radially outwards how does that pull you
inwards what is a mechanism by which it
pulls you inwards that's the question
okay and here you have in a similar
situation you have the water waves okay
and they move from left to right here
okay and so the question is you know how
does that attract you if they're going
in One Direction
so that's what we have to explain
because the gravity waves are coming
towards us here on Earth
they're coming towards us
I cannot imagine how that pulls you
especially if they're weight
and then we get to the nature of a wave
what is a wave well the wave is made out
of fields and what is a field well it
feels made out of vectors that we as we
covered that in the past okay and here
we have them okay
here's a dissection of the famous
electromagnetic wave okay it's made out
of two Fields when they call the
electric yellow one the magnetic field
and the question is what are we staring
at well what we're staring at is a bunch
of arrows blue arrows and red arrows so
what are the marrows engine arrows well
those arrows are vectors okay that's
what they are they're magnitude and
Direction the arrow stands for direction
and the height of the arrow stands for
the magnitude that's what you're staring
at and this is more or less what they're
saying that gravitation gravity waves or
gravitational waves are more or less
like electromagnetic waves okay now some
visualize them as uh trans transverse
waves you know that uh propagate up and
down and sideways uh perpendicular to
the direction of travel meaning as they
come to Earth okay uh you can visualize
them as going up and down and sideways
and that's one way of looking at the
other one is uh as a two-dimensional or
really a one-dimensional longitudinal
way which is back and forth okay so you
can look at them or a mixture of both
okay but uh what are we staring at
that's the important part because what
we're staring at is a so-called wave
that is made of fields two fields in
this case each field is made of vectors
which are just magnitude and Direction
and so what does it feel just a bunch of
moving vectors all we're talking about
is math so far we have no physical
object what is a wave two waving Fields
again we're about math none of this has
anything to do with physics okay all
that are all those are descriptions
this mathematical descriptions that's
all they are and that's all they can do
because they're interested in the
numbers and the values they're not
interested in visualizing what physical
object could be out there in the
invisible world uh in which Mother
Nature operates okay
okay so uh where do we put these uh
longitudinal or transfers or both
um gravitational waves we we have to
place them somewhere well we have to put
them both uh wave and the field of which
they're made we have to put them in the
dynamic section at the bottom uh the
ones on the top they only occupy a
single frame the yellow one there uh the
beige one at the bottom uh that requires
at least two frames of the universal
movie because you're talking about
motion okay what is motion to locations
okay location one frame uh because it's
just a set of distances motion on the
other hand requires two locations and
therefore it requires two frames of the
film and so both wave and field uh of
which the waves are made whether they're
transfers or longitudinal
um
you know they they uh there are Dynamic
Concepts and in fact we have a problem
here because they treat them as physical
objects they think that wave and field
are both physical objects as you saw um
uh Sean Carroll you know he says
particles they're they're made of fields
you know what are these feel are there
Nails uh rocks uh plants what are they
and he tells you he says no they're
numbers
that's what they are in fact the word
field came from uh Michael Faraday who
in the 1840s I think that's when he
coined the term he probably used it even
before then but that's when it first
appears in the books and what what did
he say he said look it's a region
where something is moving okay and he
called those lines that you see when you
put a magnet and you see all these
little lines of lines of force as he
called them he said look those are made
of matter the line itself not the not
the particle not the iron filing but the
the fact that they align they align he
said along something that is physical
and then Maxwell came a few years later
and he said look there's matter in
motion that's what those lines are Force
that's what a field is it's made of
motion motion of something of some
matter
so a field is dynamic concept okay there
is no I can't bring a field and put it
on the table partly because you know you
can't bring a field that's one issue but
you could make a mock-up of it but the
problem is that a field is something in
motion
okay something is moving in that region
that's what people don't always
understand and that's why I always like
to show that I haven't prepared that
today but I'd like to show how if you
put a magnet under water it collects one
iron filing at a time you can see all
the iron filing slowly going towards the
magnet because something is moving in
that region we call field field is not a
static concept with not aesthetic object
that I can put on the table feels
Something In Motion you have to identify
the something that is moving in there
and only then can you talk about
gravitational waves coming towards you
and saying look it's a field yeah but
what is the field what is it that's
moving what is this
um the vibrating thing that I'm
detecting with all these sensors
and that's what they never identify so
they said space time it's field they use
all these Concepts just to get you out
of the way but they never identify the
physical objects and that's the whole
problem with you know gravitational
waves we still don't know what
they are
okay
okay we're gonna get to some of the
questions uh comments people man one
file says
so space is not nothing
space is not nothingness
um just because you can't see ether
energy electricity magnetism gravity it
doesn't mean there is nothing there
well yeah I mean uh we got a problem
here because
um we can't see or touch you know uh
really the energy because it's a concept
gravity it's another concept you cannot
see magnetism because again it you gotta
identify the thing that is doing the
magnetism the gravity and the energy
there's something there that's doing
these things but it but see there's a
lot of things that these are things and
what they are is mathematical Concepts
this is what has not entered his brain
he doesn't realize that these are all
abstract mathematical Concepts and
they've never identified the objects
that do energy that do gravity that do
magnetism that's or electricity that's
what you got to figure out what object
is doing be saying and if you say look
there's no object because I can't see or
touch it then you're doing it with black
magic you're doing attraction between
two magnets right is that only so you're
saying that magnetism is happening
because there's nothing here absolutely
nothing because you can't see or touch
it and you're saying there's nothing
there if there's nothing there your
explanation for this phenomena
is black magic it's based on black magic
you're doing witchcraft not science you
have to put an object in there you have
to visualize it and explain it for the
audience that there is a physical object
in that region that you cannot see or
touch but you're going to explain the
mechanism of how one man yet attracts
another and had better be a thing in
there okay but uh space space is
something else space is uh not an object
it's not a thing so for that you need to
Define what a thing is you cannot say
it's not nothing
until you define what nothing and
something is first you define these
words then you can say that okay
right now you you still haven't defined
them
okay another file says
space is Zero Dimensional in a
three-dimensional Continuum containing
positions directions and distances
okay well Zero D if uh if space is Zero
Dimensional can't be in anything you
know you can't contain the Zero
Dimensional nothing
and that's the first one so you cannot
contain it so your wording is wrong okay
uh then it continues as Continuum uh is
not a thing you know he says it's a
three-dimensional Continuum no such
monster continues not a thing you can't
say it's three-dimensional like you say
three-dimensional table
you know you can't say three-dimensional
Continuum because Continuum is a concept
you got to identify or Draw the
Continuum you know what is this
three-dimensional continue okay draw it
um because if you if it's an object it's
got shape you should be able to draw it
okay and uh therefore Continuum is not
3D you cannot say that continuous 3D and
then in physics things can't contain
Concepts so you can't say that this
concept called Continuum contains
positions directions and distances those
are all Concepts you cannot contain them
okay so uh fail on all counts uh you got
to work a little harder on uh your uh
assumptions okay and your definitions
Etc
and I think the same fellow it says
Define three dimensions height width and
depth uh no death is not a dimension
death is a vector okay and there we have
it okay right at the bottom okay
dimensions are known as length within
height okay no depth there death is
motion okay and you have the three
coordinates there but depth is motion so
you have depth breath and elevation
those are the three motions vectors are
motion
uh displacement okay uh in three
mutually perpendicular directions that's
that's what a vector represents and
Mathematics doesn't use any of these
mathematics just uses number lines okay
as we discussed in the past
okay here we have uh now the file says a
square is a shape itself
the word shape is a concept in the
dictionary okay true yeah we agree
so a thing that is only a concept itself
cannot be an object
okay and where did he get that I don't
know where he says that
um
shape is the same thing as object no
it's not this is why objects have to be
more uh have more meaning to them than
only have shape no no
um
shape an object are not synonyms okay
sometimes we use them interchangeably
but they're not shape is a property
a an attribute you'd say of an object
okay so it's like this is the qualifier
and we call them adjectives in physics
so in physics an object is a noun
you can say the table has shape okay
what are we saying that we're saying the
table is the object shape is an
attribute that it possesses okay and so
we call uh things or words such as
um shape we call them adjectives they're
not nouns in physics okay so we have to
we have a new language folks and unless
you are in tune with the language you're
lost the word motion the word orbit you
know they are not the displacement none
of those are nouns not in physics all
those are verbs okay so you can't say
the orbit
no the orbit means that you're treating
orbit as a physical object okay in
physics in ordinary speech you can say
whatever you want okay you say love is a
uh an object you can say love uh exists
in physics you can't say that only
objects can exist and so on so you got
to get in tune with a language and right
now A lot of people are having problems
with the language yeah uh until you get
in tune with the language of physi
you're going to be lost
okay another fellow says objects are
forms not shapes
uh-huh because shapes are
two-dimensional representations forms
are three-dimensional
well
um
in German and in Spanish
okay at least those two language I can
tell you for sure
um there is no word for shape
that word doesn't exist they just call
the whole thing whether it's two
dimensional or three dimensional they
call it form
uh so just be aware of that shape is a
word that uh is was invented in English
and we don't care what it's used for
we're saying that in physics we're just
looking at the outer region of an object
and the object uh we don't make any
distinction between three-dimensional
and two-dimensional objects uh when we
talk about the definition of the object
we're saying it's asked to have shape
and for that all we're looking at is the
outer what we can see there or what it
has even if it doesn't require a um an
observer what it has on its own and uh
in the case of a square it has a shape
on its own whether you look at it or not
okay it could be the face of a cube and
we call that a square and that square
has shape all on its own it's
two-dimensional uh you want to use form
I don't care uh shape and form are
perfect synonyms for the purposes of
physics for efficially for the
definition of the word object so there's
no difference between one and the other
and then the other issue there is that
you know we don't have to define the
word shape okay some people say Well
define the word shape you know those are
Devil's Advocates extreme doubles
Advocate who just want to win the
discussion we're not interested in
winning the discussion we're trying to
get a definition of the word object
because we cannot do physics without
objects so it's the first word we have
to Define in physics probably next or a
second word after the word definition
itself you need to know what a
definition is then you can move to the
word object but you need to define the
word object because you cannot give a
physical interpretation a mechanism
without the word object so you need to
know what an object is in physics and
right now people use the notion that in
object is that which you can see and
touch and that's an irrational
definition you need a second object to
see your touch we can't see or touch all
the objects in the universe especially
those that are on the other side of the
universe right I can't see or touch them
and people say well but it's got the
possibility of being touched or seen and
you can't say that because you haven't
done that you haven't tried to touch or
see it
so we don't know if you can touch the
table that the Klingon has on the other
side of the universe and you say well
let me try it let me do the experiment
now we're not going to let you do the
experiment because we don't Define words
through experiments
and that's the problem okay so you can't
say that the Moon is not an object until
the asteroid touches it and hits it you
know now you can't do that hopefully the
Moon is an object before the asteroid
touches it okay so yeah the Moon is an
object because it has shape not because
the asteroid can see and touch it
okay another fellow put a comment today
he says um
well I assume that gravity is a pulling
Force rather than a pushing force is it
because you can't push on a rope
well um you got that wrong as well a
ball you know that's what they're using
quantum mechanics can only push there's
no way you can pull with a discreet ball
or particle or whatever a rope on the
other hand can push can both push and
pull you push through a rope by torquing
it
and uh all I can do is say you know grab
a rope your grandmother's rope you know
where she hangs her uh clothes and tie
it to whatever on one side of the wall
and on the other and just torque the
rope and you'll see that there's a thump
at both ends okay the signal presses on
both atoms located at the ends so yeah a
rope can push not by uh shoving it in
One Direction or the other but just by
torquing it which is the mechanism we're
proposing anyways uh here Richard
Mueller you know from Berkey he tells
you that all atoms on Earth pull on each
atom of you and you pull on each atom of
the earth he says so for example if you
have the Earth there's a big Mass here
and you have U with your little Mass
here every atom on the earth is what
pulling on every atom of you you're also
pulling on it okay so uh yeah you have
to explain pull not push you can't
explain everybody would push like some
people out there attempt to do and good
luck with that because the way they
produce it with push is the uh
you can say the Casimir away which is
you remove the particles between two
objects and whatever particles are on
outside to push them together that's the
way they they produce a pull with push
in uh toleranc way you could say you
know around about irrational way now
gravity is a pull Force okay I mean it's
an attractive Force you've got to
explain the attraction how that
attraction happens and that's what we do
with a rope because it's an extended
object and the only Force you will not
find in all the quantum mechanics in all
of mathematical physics is the force of
pool they never invented the force of
pull in mathematics why because they
never discovered what mediators Mother
Nature uses to do her daily work
I'll see you next Sunday bye bye